Speaker 1: They're now blaming rap music and
then, of course, the classic video games, as
well as COVID lockdowns for the shooting in Texas.
Anything but guns. Let's jump right into the first
clip. Ronnie Jackson, Trump's former doctor, the
guy you said, Trump, six three in ways 239. He
said, listen, they're focusing on guns, but we've
got rap music and video games to contend with.
Speaker 3: Our prayers and our thoughts are with
the families there. It's just it's unbelievable.
It's just an unbelievable evil. And I just I don't
know how someone could actually do something like
this. I think, you know, there's going to be all
kinds of discussions coming up, unfortunately,
you know, in the media regarding Second Amendment
and regarding the other issues around guns in this
country. But I think we really need to ask the
question, how could something like this happen?
How could somebody do something so evil? I mean,
what kind of person, what kind of animal can do
this? And I think, you know, we I grew up in a
small town in West Texas, not too much not not
too much smaller than the Nevada. And I can never
imagine something like this happening when I grew
up. But when I grew up, things were different. You
know, there was a focus on family and community
and church. And I think that, you know, we knew
each other. And I'm not saying that the people
that you have all you don't know each other, but I
think that that's been that's been robbed from as
our culture has changed over the last 30 or 40
years. And and there's been an attack on those
on those things in particular. And I just
think that kids are exposed to all kinds of
horrible stuff nowadays, too. I look back and
I think about the, you know, the horrible stuff
that they hear when they listen to rap music,
the video games that they watch from a really
early age with all of this horrible violence
and stuff. And I just think that, you know.
Speaker 1: Rap music and violent video games
now, is the United States the only country
with rap music now? The United States is the only
country where kids play violent video games now.
Are we the only country with this many guns per
capita? Yes, we are. Tucker Carlson talked about
the lockdowns. The lockdowns cause
mental illness and mental illness
leads to shootings. And Eubie, you do the math.
Speaker 3: Oh. So the lockdowns dramatically
increase the incidence of mental illness
among young people. And in ten days,
we've seen two mass shootings by mentally ill
young people. Could there be a connection now
that's not finger pointing. It's not to blame
vouching for yesterday's shooting. We're not
that low. We're not Joe.
Speaker 1: Biden.
Speaker 3: But if people are becoming mentally
ill because they're disconnected from others,
what can we do to connect
them to others and thereby
reduce the incidence of mental illness?
Speaker 1: That's all. So, of course,
this is a very, very pathetic misunderstanding
of what it means to say mental illness.
But we're not the only country that dealt
with COVID. In fact, many other countries
did way more in terms of restrictions. Why aren't
they having more shootings? And by the way,
Texas did almost nothing, which is where the
Uvalde shooting took place. And we're the only
ones with a mass shooting problems. And by
the way, the mass shootings didn't start
during or after COVID. They've been going on
for a very long time. So they will not stop.
They will blame anything but guns. And now I
want to talk about the mental health component.